Beverly Marsh that's who I want to see
covered on horror history sponsored by
privacy calm privacy provides new
virtual numbers so that you never have
to use it real bank information use
personalized cards for each purchase set
limits monthly or one-time limits to
make sure that you're safe to get
started go to privacy calm /cz the world
and you can get a free $5 just for
signing up each child in Derry is
terrorized by the shape-shifting it's
based on their childhood fears but
Beverly Marsh is a bit of a different
case because she's already facing the
anxieties that she would combat as an
adult because of the circumstances of
her home life welcome to horror history
my name is deface US currency in the
name of fanarts in today's lesson I'll
be analyzing the life of the only girl
in the losers Club maybe I should call
this reverse harem history to understand
Beverly we've got to start with her home
life Beverly Marsh was born in 1947 and
was the daughter of a janitor named
Alvin Marsh and a waitress named Alfred
Oh Alfred I had a lot of love for her
daughter but struggled to get
particularly close to her like your
father did but unlike Alvin she at least
had a healthy relationship with Bev al
develops inappropriate feelings towards
his daughter causing mrs. Marsh to
subconsciously pick up on the abuse
which worried her more and more as Bev
reach her pubescent years when she was
old enough Beverly started babysitting
in order to make a little bit of money
you may have also had an interest in
babysitting as a reaction to the fact
that she never really received the kind
of nurturing that she deserved from her
own parents when Beverly was 11 years
old in 1958 she was already growing into
her looks in the eyes of the 5th grade
class causing her to get bullied by
jealous female classmates like Sally
Mueller and Greta Bowie they make fun of
her the best way they know how by
insulting in her lower class upbringing
one of us lived our way out here right
I dine history her father she was poor
father was the janitor this was poor
town on the last day of school in 1958
Beverly notices a boy from her class Ben
Hanscom standing in the walkway with a
dazed look she tells him to have a nice
summer and they go their own ways but
they would cross paths again early that
summer that must have received a beating
from her dad in the meantime because
when she next sees Ben there's a bruise
on her right cheek this is most likely
because Ben leaves a love poem at her
front door and her father hates the idea
of her romantic involvement with boys so
he physically punishes her it seems that
both movie adaptations have come to the
same conclusion although the love poem
may have gotten her in trouble she still
loved it and the way that it made her
feel when she read it's a feeling that
she would remember for many years to
come
one summer day she's sitting outside the
drugstore and Richie Tozier comes by and
asked if she's going to the movies she
doesn't have the money so Richie offers
to pay for her Beverly refers to this as
her first date as a joke and pretends
that she's gonna write about it in her
diary in reality Bev is joining not only
Richie but also Ben Hanscom on the
outing the first hint of their
attraction to one another flares up
during this meal hi Richie Ben said and
then looked at Bev briefly it was if he
was afraid that an over long look might
result in a flash burn hi Beth hello Ben
she said in a strange silence fell
between the two of them it was not
precisely awkward it was Richie thought
almost powerful and he felt a vague
twinge of jealousy because something had
passed between them and whatever it had
been he had been excluded from it they
see a horror double feature and sit on
the balcony to avoid the bullies Henry
Bowers Victor Chris and belt Huggins who
had it in for Ben at the time as they're
leaving they're spotted so they try to
sneak out the side door but find
themselves surrounded along with two
other thugs that were also backing
Bowers Richie and Ben tried to fight
back his belt went after Beverly he
grabbed her ponytail and used it to
swing her against the wall which her
arms slammed into but she's somehow able
to slip away and the three of them run
from the alley to the police station
where they're able to let off the
tension with a laugh and Beverly hugs
both of them for the first time she
realizes that Ben was the one who
centered the love poem on the postcard I
think she makes this conclusion not just
based on the way that Ben acts around
her because all the boys show a certain
awkwardness next day's function
high-class luncheon
but I think Beverly knows that it's been
specifically because of the shine the
psychic connection that all of the
losers Club share which I explained in
full detail in this video once they all
feel that they're safe from Bowers they
decide to show Beverly into Berens the
spot where they all usually play
throughout that summer bill den bro and
Bradley Donovan also show up that
afternoon and Beverly finds that she's
got a crush on bill
mostly because of his natural leadership
ability that evening Beverly has her
first encounter with the monster that
lurks below Darren it but her experience
goes much differently than any of her
classmates if you're smart with your
online accounts you probably have
different passwords for different
accounts that way if one password gets
compromised you don't have to worry
about changing every single account so
when you buy stuff online with a credit
card why should that be any difference
with privacy calm you can create virtual
card numbers for each different vendor
that you purchase from they also let you
set limits on each card so no vendor can
ever charge you more than expected and
if anyone tries to pull a fast one
you'll know who's responsible the
service is free to use so there's no
reason not to try it in fact as a
special incentive for horror history
viewers they're gonna give you $5.00 if
you sign up using my link privacy calm
sloshed easy you can use that literally
anywhere you want you can transfer it to
yourself withdraw it and then draw emo
Abraham Lincoln fan art on it if you
want personally I'd just spend it
privacy calm /c Z's world Beverly is
home washing up when she hears a voice
whisper helped me from her bathroom
drain her first thought is that some kid
got access to the pipes and was pranking
her until she hears the voice from mark
we all want to meet you Beverly she also
sees something move in the drain and
smells an unpleasant scent and hears
voices of the kids who had gone missing
or died during that summer like Matthew
Clemens Betty rip some and Veronica
Grogan a bubble of blood emerges in the
drain and pops spattering into the sink
the voices tell her that they're with
the clown the creature the mummy the
werewolf and that they all float and
that she'll float to when she's down
there with them more blood Torrence from
the drain and gets on the wall in mirror
Beverly runs out of the bathroom most of
the other kids in Derry see it's in the
form of some kind of monster but the
blood represents what disturbs Beverly
the most her first period and her
budding sexuality this is what caused
her father to see her differently her
female classmates to dislike her and
many of the men in town
take on a predatory role towards her
this is reflected in what happens next
she brings her father and to look at the
math but he's unable to see it in fact
none of the adults can see it because
they've already reached and accepted
their adulthood only kids have to deal
with this fear of growing up the next
morning Bev wakes up to the sound of the
alarm clock coming from her parents room
another more subtle symbol for the
abusive behavior for dad in most cases
you wouldn't hear some houses alarm
clock unless you're sleeping with them
but the literal explanation for this
isn't the family's poor and lives in a
tiny apartment so she can hear it from
her room Bev and her mom are supposed to
clean the house that day but her mom has
to leave to help out one of her friends
that had been in a car accident before
heading out though Alfreda asked
Beverley if her father ever touches her
what Beverley looked at her mother
totally perplexed God her father touched
her everyday I don't get what you feel
free to brushed it off and had it act
like many adults in Derry she too is
inclined to ignore the fact that there's
a problem that's part of what it does to
the town Beverley cleans the house but
avoids the still bloody bathroom after
hearing penny wises laugh emanating from
the drain she goes out that afternoon
and at 3:00 p.m. comes across a banal
Bradlee Donovan and another boy from
school
Casper we're all pitching pennies in
Richards alley next to the drugstore
this is a game commonly played in the
50s where you have to try to throw your
penny against a wall and whoever lands
theirs closest to the edge wins all the
pennies Beverley joins in the game and
wins seven out of the next eight rounds
netting her a whopping 24 cents Bradley
Donovan feeling the frustration of
having taken eight consecutive Elza
hughster of cheatin Ben stands up for
his girl and he's basically about to
fight Bradley Donovan but Beverley gives
him his pennies back claiming that she
was never playing for keeps
but I guess that just made things more
humiliating for Big D because he knocked
those emo Abraham Lincoln's right out of
her hand and said you're just a little
bit that's all cheater cheater your
mother's a prostitute but with a W for
some reason this insult hit Beverly
harder than expected and made her think
of that morning when her mom had dropped
the question does he ever touch you Eddy
and Ben tried to comfort her and she
cries out my mother is not a she's a
waitress Bev Ben and Ed's put their
money together to get ice cream fry pays
and Beverly opens up to the boys about
the incident with the blood the previous
night's local juice tan URIs also shows
up and Beverly tells them the whole
story because she feels that these guys
are there in a way that Bradley was not
Stan felt like one of them and I believe
this goes back to the idea that the kids
who would
the seven members of the losers Club
have a stronger shine than others and
thus a tighter bond the boys agree to
take a look at the drain with her and
they have to sneak in the back door in
order to prevent her neighbor mrs.
Bolton from telling her father that she
had been seen with the boys they help
her clean the blood and take the dirty
rags down to the washeteria in town
where Ben and Stan offer additional
comfort by sharing their own stories of
Pennywise encounters that night Beverley
puts away the clean rags and gets the
bravery to try to run a measuring tape
down the drain to see how far it really
was and after reaching 18 feets the full
length of the tape she still had not hit
the bottom the voice tells her she'll
die if she tries to fight and when she
brings back up the tape it's covered in
blood and another burst of blood oozed
out of the drain
this time she plugs it I'm sure you can
figure out what that represents before
being left to clean it up alone this
time crying as she did so things got
worse before they got better the month
of July would begin shortly after and
Beverly would get into a heated argument
with the boy that she was most
interested on believe it or not
Bradley Donovan did not come back around
after that last incident but that's okay
because the group had plenty of be names
already like Beverly bill and Ben they
would often meet up with Eddie Stan and
Ritchie to play in the Barrens and one
afternoon in July 3rd bill den bro gets
a bad feeling and tells his friends to
create a stash of wrongs which would
soon be used to fend off Bauer's and his
gang and protect Mike Hanlon
during this apocalyptic Rock fight
Beverley only had one Rock which he used
in mail Henry in the stomach but perhaps
the most important part of the fight was
when she got hit by a large rock thrown
by Henry sending Ben into an outrage
when he tackled Henry and the others
covered him during his hat at the
conclusion Beverly specifically thanked
Ben for standing up for her and Mike
became the seventh and final one to join
the groove which would be referred to as
the losers Club the same name that Henry
Bowers had used to address them for the
next week were sad with the losers Club
focused on building an underground
clubhouse in the Barrens which was
supposed to keep them hidden from Bowers
and his gang Beverly contributed by
nailing the crosspieces and to help
support the structure and going into
town with Stan to buy the hinges
necessary to create the swinging door
near the completion of the clubhouse
they take a break and Mike shows the
group some Pennywise sightings littered
throughout Jerry's history and his
father's historical photo album and they
all have a scare when it's nearly jumps
out of the page to kidnap them before
the end of the month the clubhouse is
vanished
and the next step the losers Club takes
to try to bring down Pennywise is
performing the smoke hole ritual this
was a Native American practice where the
Chiefs would breathe in smoke and
supposedly have visions about what they
should do next do not try this it is
dangerous and will not work
the losers decide that they'll attempt
the ritual inside of their Clubhouse so
bill nominates Beverly to stay up and
save them if they pass out this pisses
AR off though she doesn't want to be
left out just because she's the only
girl so she comes up with an alternate
solution she pulls out her matchbook and
lights one match then she puts the burnt
side down with the six other matches and
each member takes one whoever got the
burnt one was supposed to stay up top
however after everyone had pulled and
none of them were burnt anymore the
losers take this as a sign that they're
all supposed to take part this may have
happened due to intervention from mattre
and the turtle the rival entity of it
but for more on that you should watch
the penny wise horror history the fire
was started was one of Beth's matches
and she ended up being the fourth one to
climax leaving just bill Ritchie and
Mike after bill climbed out some time
passed before Bev and the others decided
to pull out the last two and after they
had recovered they told the story of how
they had seen the arrival of its many
years ago after having seen the arrival
of it the next step was decide how they
would fight it later that month after
attempting to visit Eddie as he sat in a
hospital with a broken arm the remaining
six of them took turns firing at cans in
the Barrens with Bill slingshots Beverly
was by far the best hitting all ten cans
nine of which were dead-on shots they
planned to melt down Ben's silver
dollars to create ammunition because
they believed that silver would hurt the
monster just like in the werewolf movies
before getting the chance to put the
plan into action Beverly runs into a
little complication while practicing
with the slingshot alone one day in the
Barrens she heard some noises down by
the dump and approached thinking that it
was her friends what she found instead
was the bowers again they were lighting
farts on fire and that has to hide
inside of a junk car to avoid being seen
Victor and belch head outs leaving just
Henry and an extremely disturbed kid
Patrick hochstätter she basically ends
up seeing some queer stuff go down
between them and Patrick blackmails
Henry one-dollar to keep quiet about it
Henry snaps back at Patrick telling him
that if he says anything he'll reveal
what Patrick was hiding in the abandoned
refrigerator in the dumb Beverly doesn't
know what that meant but on her way out
of the Barrens she noticed Patrick was
thrashing around and dancing near the
fridge before disappearing down the path
as he screamed she approached the fridge
and saw blood the very thing it's had
used to frighten her before but this
time it was real she also heard her
father's voice and thought for sure it
must have been a hallucination because
her dad was out of town that day
but I personally think that it was using
the form of mr. Marsh one of the things
that Beverly feared most
she was also attacked by a small blood
sucking leech with wings when she
smashed it it continued to leech off her
and she had to physically pick it off
there were a couple more parasites near
the fridge and without thinking she
tried to shoot one of them with a
slingshot she felt that she had missed
her shot but saw the ball bearing
strangely curved and destroy when the
leeches at the time she didn't know how
that was possible
she was only beginning to understand the
power that she and the other losers had
simply by believing in themselves after
that she continued to run down the path
apparently choosing the lesser of two
evils by risking seeing Patrick which he
saw instead was an even bigger mess of
blood and understands Hawk stutters fade
when she hears the laughter of the clown
coming from inside one of the pumping
stations connected to the sewer Beverley
ran from the Barrens to find the others
and four hours later they all marched
back to the junkyard to investigate they
saw a message written in blood stop now
before I kill you all a word to the wise
from your friend
Pennywise bill asked Beverley and the
other losers to help him avenge his
brother Georgia who was killed by AIDS
and together they hug in the rain
silently making a pact to take down the
monster when they went ahead to carry
out the plan Beverley would see even
more disturbing things that would stay
with her for years and years to come
I'm evening of July 23rd the 7 of them
played Monopoly at Bill's house as they
waited for the melted down silver to
harden into the silver slugs to be shot
at Pennywise Beverley called her mom and
said that she was at community house and
that she would get a ride home from Bill
den Burroughs father upon hearing this
her mom has to clarify with her that
she's not on a date and asked if any of
her girlfriends are there this line
highlights the distance between Bev and
her mom Alfreda doesn't even realize
that Bev has no female friends so she
has to make up some lie about a pair of
girls on top of the line that she's
already telling about her whereabouts
after the silver slugs were finished
Beverley asked bill to hold on to them
until it was time to use them
she was afraid of her father finding
them and taking them from her which just
goes to show the complete lack of
privacy that Beverley had at home she
also grows more interested in Bill
the night goes on thinking if he held my
hand I think I'd be so glad I'd probably
die two days later around 10 a.m. the
losers Club arrived at its lair its
gateway between the sewers that sprawled
underneath Derry and the surface 29
niebolt streets after venturing upstairs
Beverly opens a cupboard and an ordinary
rat comes scampering out sped was so on
edge that she nearly fired the first
slug and wasted it on nothing more than
an ordinary rodents but she was able to
hold back from doing so they also
discovers something described as a girly
book in one corner and the woman on the
cover who winks at Ben was actually a
younger version of mrs. Kirsch another
form of ID's that Bev would encounter 27
years later upon returning to Derry she
remembers this small detail from the
magazine cover nearly three decades
later which I find to be a powerful
indicator of just how traumatizing the
trip into 29 niebolt must have been for
her after only previously encountering
bipedal forms of it's very briefly on
the page and will Hammonds photo album
they come across three doors the last of
which was a destroyed bathroom with
white shards scattered about as if the
toilet bowl had exploded they would soon
find out how the room came to assume
this corrosive stains
it's rushed up from the pipes leading
down to the sewer in what is described
as its own form that explodes out into
the bathroom taking the form of the
werewolf in a Derry high school
letterman jackets Bev has two slugs two
shoots two chances to take its down she
fires the slingshot at the monster but
misses her first shot Mike finds the
ball bearing and gives it back to Beth
the werewolf sprang at a bill in an
attempts to take down their leader first
and Beverley fired another shot but it
missed and punched a hole through the
wall the creature then goes after Ben
and slashes at him and with her final
shot she pierces its snout sending up a
torrent of blood and saving the boy
whose poem and carried her through the
most horrible weeks she had ever endured
still it's continued to come after them
and with no ammo left she pulled back to
slang once again and believed she could
hurt it with her mind and this caused
its to dive back into the drain
screaming I'll kill you all as it
descended into the sewers just as silver
was able to hurt it based on the
childish beliefs that tactics from the
movie would actually work Bev was able
to scare it away just by motioning the
empty slingshots during the attack
Beverly's blouse was cut open by the
werewolves Claus
so bill offers up his shirt for her to
cover herself with it it would not be
the first or last time there was
romantic tension between the two but it
would be the last event of Bachelor
on August 10th 1958 Alvin Marsh went
into a mad rage upon learning that
Beverly was hanging out in the Barrens
with a bunch of boys and after whacking
her on the face decided to discuss and
take advantage of the situation by
making Beverly prove to him that she's
still intact he had also been down to
the Barrens and saw her smoking causing
him to lose control and start breaking
things in the house which made Beverly
begin to fear for her life at some point
she got the idea that it wasn't just him
though the influence of its was helping
push his anger over the edge she even
hints at the idea that Pennywise was the
one to show mr. Marsh what she was doing
in the Barrens or at least give him the
idea to look there I think this one line
does a good job of explaining how its
influence over Alvin works you come back
here no she said you want to hurt me I
love you daddy
but I when you're like this you can't do
it anymore it's making you do it but you
let it in the effect of its on mr. Marsh
and the intensity of how scary he had
become are both illustrated after Alvin
tries to pounce on her and she runs out
the door he chased right after her into
town and the little neighbor boy Lars
ceremonious saw him chase after Beverly
in a crazed frenzy a vision that would
give him nightmares for weeks in the
nightmares he saw mr. Marsh turning into
a spider as he chased his daughter out
the door which of course represents the
final form of its that the losers would
soon face aside from this being the day
that she would put an end to the current
cycle of its they've also had a
phenomenal cardio day
[Music]
because the chased by her father
continued well into dairies downtown
area where Bev hid under a dumpster
truck which Alvin crawled under to try
to get her she took off into a smaller
alley which her father ran past and she
was finally able to lose him she picks
up a pretty nasty smell from being under
the truck though and I think it
represents a foul version of the smell
that's described in the novel earlier
that summer the smell represents lust
her father's lust for her and her
discovering lust for the first time that
summer when meeting bill den bro but the
smell of the garbage truck that gets on
her represents the awful feeling that
she has when she fears her own parents
and wants nothing more than to repel him
but Alvin a janitor by trade who's
continually coming after her
unfortunately for Beverly it was out for
revenge for what she did to it at 29
year old street a couple of weeks ago
and Alvin Marsh wasn't the only one that
it's had sent after her the morning
before mr. Marsh's mad fit of rage
chased Beverly out of the house and into
Derry a familiar voice told Henry Bowers
to gather Belgian Victor and go to
Kansas Street that afternoon Henry who
was holding onto the smallest sliver of
sanity obeys the command and shows up to
find Beverly there in a panic after just
escaping her father the voice speaks to
Henry again this time telling him to
kill her and another chase ensues
[Music]
Beverly must have been tired from the
long run away from her dad because
although she had no problem running away
from the bullies after the movie theater
incidents this time Henry catches up to
her and grabs her hair Bev's hair has
been somewhat of a motif for her appeal
as established in Ben's poem in fact in
the 2017 adaptation she cuts off a good
portion of it after her father creepily
strokes the locks hanging down around
her shoulders there are a couple of
adults who see what Henry is about to do
to her but they don't do anything to
help another example of the so called
disease that plays the adults of dairy
and sledding the evils spread one nut
shot later Beverly's running into the
Barrens with Henry limping after her
along with his goons Victor in belch
she's able to distance herself a little
bit and heads for the clubhouse where
she finds Ben by himself and quickly
explains what's going on after hearing
that Bowers had 100% lost it Ben brings
down the hatch shutting them in the
clubhouse the camouflage of the
clubhouse worked perfectly because the
bullies came up and stood directly on
the lid without realizing it it's
Beverly hold on tightly to bat she
worried that the dumpster smelled they
covered her would give them away and
they struggled not to laugh and belches
stupid comments meanwhile the weight of
the three bullies is starting to crack
the wooden hatch and Ben and Bev were in
danger of them falling through into the
clubhouse the bullies move on just in
time though and once Beverly assured
that they're gone her and Ben share
laugh I think the danger of that
experience brought her and Ben closer
together because she then decides to
thank Ben for writing the poem to her at
the beginning of that summer before long
they realized that they better warn the
others not to go to the Barrens with
Henry prowling the area clearly out for
blood a little more cardio couldn't hurt
right
they run into town and they're able to
find Bill Eddy Ritchie's Stan and Mike
the group led by Bill decides to go back
into the Barrens under the idea that
it's not Bowers property and they
shouldn't have to be afraid of going to
their favorite spots when they arrived
there he realizes something that Bev had
concluded a little bit earlier that day
that Bowers was being controlled by its
and by defeating its they could put an
end to most of their problems so as they
head to the pumping station where they
can climb down into the sewers and
confront Pennywise they were attacked by
some rocks that fly out from the bushes
yeah why not one more time okay that's
getting old after getting into the sewer
they traversed the network of pipes
until they eventually make its to the
layer of it where bill goes head-to-head
with Pennywise in a void and known as
the macro verse most of the losers
thought that it was dying his bill and
it's returned to the real world but Bev
was one of the two members who seemed a
little unsure even after defeating it
they still had one more dangerous
obstacle to overcome as they search for
the exit of the sewers the group felt
that they were drifting apart the power
that had United them in their battle
seemed to be fading and they were unable
to navigate their way out of the dark
labyrinth of pipes the seven of them
needed some kind of spark to bring them
closer to each other again
and Beverly realizes how she can do it
her role is to share her love with the
others one by one she embraces them and
just as the defeat of its marks the
beginning of their adulthood by showing
their ability to overcome a horrible
trauma this love scene represents the
first step of that transition to
adulthood which begins with their
teenage years and includes dating and
relationships I mean if you read the
book it's a bit more graphic so moving
on they find their way out of the
tunnels and make a Blood Pact promising
to come back to destroy its if it's ever
returned later that month Beverley
enters middle school and she and Richie
Tozier sign up for the talent show were
there to perform a couple of dances one
called the hellzapoppin
and another known as Lindy hopping I
would demonstrate but the only dances
that I'm familiar with are called
moshing and headbang in another Stephen
King novel 11/22/63 an English teacher
named Jake Epping time travels from 2011
to 1958 in order to try to prevent the
Kennedy assassination but he takes a
detour in Derry where he encounters
Beverley and Ritchie practicing for this
talent show and a picnic area near the
Barrens Beverley and Richie kind of
connect with Jake because they unlike
many others are able to understand the
supernatural aspect
Jake's TAS can see him as less of an
outsider than most of those living in
the late 50s and early 60s not much is
known about Beverly's years as a young
adult aside from the fact that she moved
to Chicago and becomes a clothing
designer at Delia fashions where she
creates clothing for a younger clientele
I think we can assume the reason she
left area was to get away from her
abusive father but she ends up falling
into the same trap by marrying an
abusive husband this is actually a
common coping tactic for victims of
abuse like Beverly it's known as
revitalization and according to a
research brief that looked at the number
of studies between 2000 and 2011 victims
of childhood abuse are 2 to 13 times
more likely to put themselves in a
similar situation in adulthood so for
Beverly she subconsciously associated
her father's actions with the love of a
parent and developed feelings after
meeting Tom Rogen at a singles bar in
1981 and discovering that they worked in
the same building together the two would
get together and start a new brand
called the Beverly fashions one day they
were together in the car on the way home
from a party and he told her he never
wants to see her smoking again she
agrees and tosses the cigarette but a
few weeks later after a movie she lights
one again by habit and he gets mad and
strikes her in the face when she
responded he beat her up inside of the
car and makes her repeat the phrase I'll
never do it again without your
permission as if she were a child
Tom's aversion to smoking is interesting
because that's exactly what set Bev's
father over the edge to attack her on
that August day in 1958 the act of
smoking is similar to Beverly's action
of dating an abusive man Tom because
both are examples of her willingly doing
something harmful to herself in a
subconscious habitual way smoking is
prohibited by both of her abusers but
when she's with her friends in the
losers Club she uses her matchbook in
more constructive ways like lighting the
fire and the smoke hole that taught them
more about its and using matches to
light the way as they attempted to
navigate their way out of the sewers and
of course the key line in Ben's poem to
Beverly says your hair is winter fire
fire and smoke go hand in hand and Bev
would go on to be with Ben at the end of
the store but first she would have to
endure four years of an abusive marriage
with Tom Rogan because they were married
in a civil ceremony three months after
the smoking incident and just like the
day where she was chased out of the
house by her father she would go through
another domestic incident after an
unexpected call had come from Derry in
1985
[Music]
the call from Mike Hamlin came in after
Beverly and Tom had already gone to bed
as Tom went to the fridge to get a beer
Mike explained to Beverly that it had
come back in dairy although she didn't
fully remember what it was she knew it
was serious and immediately started
packing she also fell victim to a bad
old habit and lit up a cigarette so when
Tom came back into the room he was
furious with her he smacked her in the
face just like that day in the car and
then he brought out the belts she
bombards him by throwing a series of
glass cosmetic bottles it had been her
impeccable aim that had helped the
losers out in the rock fight and helped
her drive it into the sewers with a
slingshot at 29 Abel and this time it
would help her escape Tom's attack she
fled down three blocks barefoot where
she found someone to give her 40 cents
to use a payphone and contact her friend
came a call who gets her a cat during
the ride the names of all of bets
childhood friends slowly come back to
her she gets the Kay's house Kay had
seen the relationship that they've had
with Tom and was very happy that she'd
finally left him so she offers some
money trip I have to take a cab from
Chicago to the airport in Milwaukee
just in case tom was gonna try to ambush
her at O'Hare or Midway on the flight
from Milwaukee to Logan Airport in
Boston she sits next to a man that she
finds attractive and he asked what's
happened to her hand in reference to the
red mark
Tom's belt had left on her during the
fight she lies to him and says that she
slammed it in the car door lying about
her bad relationship has become her
go-to just as she hid what her father
had done to her from her mother as a
child she also keeps the secret from her
friends when she arrives in Derry and
they all meet for a reunion lunch she
even tells them that tom was the one to
transform her into a talent in regards
to her career because his overbearing
control over her somehow warped her mind
to believe that she didn't hold any
merit on her own which is another reason
that it's so important for her and the
other losers that had returned to Derry
to regain their childhood memories and
rediscover the power that had once
defeated EDS when they get their fortune
cookies at the end of the meal each one
is manipulated by its to represent the
losers individual fears
Beverly's cookie sprays out blood
possible reminder of the blood and her
father's sink or perhaps this time a
reminder of a bloody footprint that she
left after cutting her foot on the
perfume bottle that she threw at Tom
while she was escaping the ha
Bevell Eddie and Richie and Ben each set
out on personal journeys through dari to
try to reclaim some of their old
memories and Beverly finds herself
standing outside the clean clothes
washeteria or her friends it helps her
clean the bloody rags she decides to
walk to her old house and see if her
father was still there she rings the
doorbell for Marsh but instead an old
lady named mrs. Kirsch answers the door
informs her that her father had passed
away five years prior mrs. Kirsch
invites her in for tea but things start
to go weird as they're sitting together
the woman's teeth start rotting and her
eyes go yellow never realizes she's in
trouble when the ladies dress turns
black like a sky and she starts talking
about her father or rather her father
[Music]
she tells about her father Robert gray
who was also known as penny wise of the
dancing clown and upon hearing these
words Everly gets this idea that her tea
is actually but from the sewers how did
you not realize that immediately Beverly
I mean you should be able to distinguish
Earl Grey from Robert gray pretty easily
mrs. Kirsch warns her to get out of town
because no one who dies here ever really
dies I she begins to transform into a
witch from the fairy tale Hansel and
Gretel this witch had always been
something that scared Beverly the whole
apartment starts turning to candy and
she runs for the door but she can hear
her father's voice booming after her
when she looks back at the house she
sees the clown
Pennywise holding the leg of a child and
a balloon with the words it came from
outer space
which is the name of another 50s horror
movie that also happens work with
Stephen King's monster it's her father
penny wise and foolish from Hansel and
Gretel all share the common traits of
being monsters who prey on children
after getting across the street Beverly
looks back again and sees just a
deserted house but finds her fingers
stained with chocolate that night's the
losers all meet at the library and
recall more of their memories about the
initial battle with penny wise before
calling it a night that realizes that
their hands are all bleeding and starts
to scream the scars where they each cut
their hands to make the blood oath in
1958 had reopened and they all joined
hands once more that is hit with a wave
of thought after which she remembers
everything from her childhood including
but not limited to Radley
but after leaving the library bill and
Everly walked back to the hotel together
hand-in-hand and some of her old
feelings are starting to come back
she asked build the kisser and he does
in fact they end up going back to Bill's
hotel room together and although bill
has some second thoughts about being
unfaithful on his marriage Everly does
not which is fair because she already
walked out on her marriage that night he
would give her her best time ever and
maybe understands for the first time
what a healthy relationship could be
like they sleep together in Bill's room
and she thinks back through all of the
years of her childhood that is until her
dreams are cut short by another shocking
phone call
[Applause]
[Music]
after receiving a panicked call from
Eddie Cass Brack Everly and bill rushed
to his room the stage of a surprise
attack by an escaped Henry Bowers who is
now dead
Beverly thinking of the adults who
refused to help her when Bowers had to
come after her as a child agrees that
taking Eddie to the hospital in Derry
may not be a good option she dials the
library to talk to Mike but the police
chief
Andrew Rademacher picks up and informs
her that Henry has already gotten there
first and put Mike in the hospital the
group decides that they've already let
this go on too long and heads back to
the sewers for a final showdown with it
they climb back into the sewers and make
their way to the door of its inner
sanctum
the one thing that none of them can
really remember properly is what lies
beyond the storm but Beverly does
remember that they thought it's using
the ritual of chud they entered the lair
and are once again greeted by the giant
spider form of it this time however it's
bill and Ritchie who entered the Mack
reverse to battle it's in the ritual
chip meanwhile Eddy tries to fight it in
the physical world but takes a major L
and gets his arm ripped off Beverley
holds him in her arms during his final
moments and Ritchie and Bill went on to
finish off it's deeper in the chamber
while Ben goes to destroy its eggs and
prevent any potential offspring Beverly
had previously saved the entire group by
providing her love so it's only fitting
that she be there for Eddie during his
final moments after it had been defeated
the eggs smashed and Eddie laid to rest
the others reconvened with Beverley and
they headed out of the chamber for the
final time they ended up climbing out of
a cracked sewer pipe to discover a flood
that had destroyed the town above them
during the final battle and with Bill's
wife being rescued she says goodbye to
him with one last hug a photo of this
appears in the newspaper with the
caption survivors meanwhile Beverly has
been growing closer to Benton with the
reacquired memories of the times that
they shared in their childhood and the
realization of his authorship of the
poem that she had always treasured with
no more abusive people in her life she
finally decides to quit smoking the four
remaining losers excluding Mike who is
still alive but still in the hospital
decided to go out for breakfast there
were four of them but Beverly notices
their reflection in a window where she
sees six Eddie and Stan had joined them
in spirits it was probably not long
after when Beverly revealed the truth to
Ben that she didn't really have anywhere
to go after having left her husband so
Ben invites her to go with as he drives
back across the country to Nebraska so
on June 5th nineteen
five they set out together Mike talks to
them on the phone before being released
from the hospital and something tells
him they'll end up getting married
Beverly Marsh Beverly Rogan and then
perhaps Beverly Hanscom was the thread
that tied together the losers Club her
love picked the group up at their lowest
her 99 accuracy saved them on countless
occasions and she was there to help
through practically everything as they
saved Derry from the curse of the
creature who had created chaos there for
as long as the town's history goes now
if you want to hear about the histories
of other characters for minutes click
the playlist on the left and if you love
horror let me know what franchise I
should cover next on horror history and
remember to subscribe to seize these
worlds for new Horrors every week bring
that death belt for notifications and
I'll see you in the next one
assuming we both survive I am taking a
nap